ça devait passer pour un suicide pauvre
abruti tu lui avais dit de laisser le FL
de Laer le fling de pas ramener FL m' je
sais pas pourquoi il l' ramené je sais
pas j'ai d comme vous m'avez dit tu lui
as dit de tirer par devant alors
pourquoi il a tiré par derrière c'est
quand même simple par devant c'est par
devant et par derrière c'est par
derrière il faire croire que c'était
tout bonnement un suicide ça ressemble à
un meurre et ça devra pas y ressembler
c'estair j'ai dit dans leont J'ai enin
front comme ça j'ai comme m'z dit je
prets je le promets je le jure sur mes
enfants j sur mes enfant C d'accord
calme-toi ressaisis-toi et ne jure pas
sur tes enfants tu passes pour un crétin
je suis non non je suis pas un crrétin
j'ai tout bien
fait